nous on défend le bilan du président de
la république ça notre objectif c'est
pouvoir parler aussi aux jeunes en
reprenant leurs codes là le but c'est
que les jeunes se balade dans la rue où
tombe sur cette affiche voilée kahn est
fixée celle que ça leur donne envie
aussi d'apprendre ce qu'on a créé pour
eux
car donatrice des jeunes avec macron à
paris aujourd'hui on a pris un tractage
avant et après on va se retrouver pour
faire un apéro dont on appelle ça les
tac les tractages appel au collège
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout le mal qu'on peut se donner sur
tout le territoire surtout les corps on
a déroulé
on est organisée on a des adhérents la
plupart on est amis ça fait bien se
retrouver tous ensemble d'armand
c'est l'un des moments légers et on
attend ça on se dit le matin à la une
actuellement on est content parce qu il
ya à la fois cependant vert
ça nous met en joie
[Musique]
j'allais au menu ce dont je prenais ce
chemin tous les matins et du coup il y
avait un homme ont été très tôt du coup
il est 7 heures du matin il est un homme
derrière entre les barrières derrière
moi où il était nu alcoolisées et qui
avait tenté de maillots sexuellement
donc il a essayé de m'attraper
je me suis débattue fin j'ai crié je me
suis débattu des poussées et je les ai
couru jusqu'à l'arrêt de bus
[Musique]
j'aide pas forcément d'accord avec aucun
des candidats désignés à la fin et puis
est arrivé emmanuel macron en campagne
les que pour la quasi première fois dans
la 5ème république quelqu'un qui veut
dire que la des bonnes idées à droite et
les bonnes idées à gauche et que l'on
privilégie le pragmatisme ou dogmatisme
pense que c'était la personne qui avait
compris comment il fallait entre 8 mai
réformer la société
et ça meurt tous les trois jours
le célèbre nous devons tous nous sentir
responsable je vous prie d'observer une
minute de silence en hommage à ces
femmes battues violées
moi quand j'ai entendu ce discours j'ai
juste eu envie de concrétiser mon
engagement j'étais du coup déjà
intéressé par évidemment les hits et
emmanuel macron mais pour la première
fois un président de la république qui
proclame que du coup l'égalité
femmes-hommes c'est la grande cause du
quinquennat ce n'était jamais arrivé
alors que passait un sujet qu'on avait
juste sous le nez et que ça faisait des
années que personne n'agissait
[Musique]
mais toi je voulais voir hier soir pour
le panneau est capable on a accepté de
débattre avec nous je dis donc ce sera
un débat jours avec toulouse à nous
apprendre 35 personnes dans un bar j'ai
fait un visuel tout un bon choix pour
trouver un titre genre accrocheur tu
vois trois mots écouter dialoguer qu'on
va encore temps là ouais trop forte tac
et on est bon l'imparfait
[Musique]
alors oui aujourd'hui je suis portable
de la majorité provinciale depuis un an
mais en réalité je suis une militante
mois là où je me sens le plus à l'aise
le plus utile sans porte à porte c'est
en tractage c'est dark voilà des
échanges des relations et ce débat que
vous pouvez mener c'est le kilomètre
zéro de la communication vous êtes tous
ici le kilomètre zéro de la
communication ce qu'on n'arrive pas à
débattre échanger avec tout le monde
moule sur les plateaux vous là bas on
vous passe le relais il faut qu'on aille
chercher voit pas revoir et quand je dis
voix par voie et ça c'est important pour
la république pour la nation pour
certains on a connu il ya longtemps un
peu et puis on t'a vu faire plein de
choses et puis fait la campagne que toi
ta porte parole donc et on est content
et ça prouve aussi qu'on ait un
mouvement où tout le monde peut avancer
vient de se jouer à l'ancien terrain de
se joue sur des prétendues études ou des
prétendus compétences donc je pense que
c'est important de dire que tout le
monde peut trouver ce qu'il a envie de
faire dans ce mouvement